p.m. in the adult cross room uh we're
reading through the gospel of Mark in a
way that's open to hard and difficult
theological questions um this is a great
class if you're deconstructing or have
questions or things like that it's a
great place to be uh finally oh actually
not finally um oh
sorry um we do have over here if you see
this black bucket this is kind of like
an accessibility bucket that we've made
um the purpose of that is if you are
anxious about being in a church setting
if you are a part of the disability
Community or if you're just feeling a
little fidgety today um there's tools
over there for you um to soothe you or
whatever you might need we have
headphones fidget toys things like that
so glad you're here okay
now um with
sorry these
candles are a sign of the presence of
Christ Among Us fully Divine and fully
human now we exit the kingdom of noise
hurry and productivity and we enter the
kingdom of Silence Stillness and
simplicity a Sacred Space a place for
prayer worship and
adoration a place to behold Christ
revelation of God and heartbeat of
creation allow The unforced rhythms of
Grace to find you and to mend your heart
may we all come home
thanks Rachel well guys can y'all stand
with us I mean if you want to we can
just fill in this space y'all can gather
up here we can have a Kumbaya Circle
this 4 P.M service like I feel like
there's something that's like very
tangible and special about being in this
room together like the what is that Army
like the few the proud the brave like
yes there we go oh Marines that's what
it is anyways I'm just like let's do
what Miss Vicki talked about like let's
be family let's be here let's be present
and share our hearts together um in this
room as we worship so you guys sing
along uh Joe's going to lead us in this
first song and I also wanted to mention
you may notice uh we've had a lot of
sound questionable things going on our
main speakers have been going in and out
and so we have like speakers set up here
to hopefully help transfer the sound
back to you guys um
but if it feels at some point like huh
something just went away it probably
did we're just kind of rolling with the
punches and trying to be flexible and
trying to make the best of what we have
so uh lift your voice it is our
instrument offstage you know today and
every day um we are in this together so
let's just sing out and and uh let our
hearts be connected as we worship a God
who is here and present and loves us
[Music]
I love you
Lord for you have delivered
me I love you
Lord for you have delivered my soul from
Death my feet from stumbling I will walk
in the land of the living my soul found
my feet from stumbling I will walk in
the land of the
[Music]
living I love you
Lord for you have delivered
me I love you you
Lord for you have delivered my soul from
Death my feet from stumbling I will walk
in the land of the living my soul from
in the land of the living
[Music]
o I Will Bless You Lord For You Heard My
Cry I reach out my hand and you saved my
life I will bless you Lord for you heard
my ple and the god of Heaven turned is
here to me I will bless you Lord for
unending love for your grace and mercy
raining down from above I Will Bless You
Lord to the very end I will call on you
long as I may
live I love you
Lord for you have delivered me
I love you
Lord for you have delivered my soul from
Death my feet from stumbling I will walk
in the land of the living my soul from
in the land of the living
[Music]
all right kiddos you know where to go we
love you guys have a great time with
your teachers and love on them for us
thank you so much Kelly and Katie and
Abby and the nursery teachers in the
back we're going to transition into the
prayers of the people so you guys can
follow along on the screens and read the
parts in red aloud
together Jesus for the city of saxi
Texas and for every city and community
and all who live in them we pray to you
for the Good Earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it we pray to you for the old
and the sick for the Widow and the
orphan for the injured and suffering we
pray to you for the poor and the
oppressed the unemployed and destitute
for prisoners and captives and all who
remember and care for them we pray to
you for the vulnerable the marginalized
and those unjustly targeted for their
gender sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you for those
experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotion Health we pray
to you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to
[Music]
you Johnny
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence amen
[Music]
there's Ace when the Heart Is Under
Fire another way when the walls are
closing
in and when I look at the space between
where I used to be and this
Reckoning I know I will never be
alone there was another in the
fire standing next to me there was
another in
the holding back the
SE should I ever need
reminding how I've been set free there
is a cross that bears the burden where
another di for me there is another in
the
[Music]
fire all my death for dead benath the
wall
[Music]
I'm no longer a slave to my sin
anymore should I fall in the space
between what remains of me and this
Reon either way I will bow to the things
of this
world I know I will never be
alone there is another in the
fire standing next to me there is
another in
the holding back the
SE should I ever need
reminding what power Set Me Free there
is a grave that holds no body now the
power lives in me there is another in
the
fire oh
there is another in the
fire
oh there is another in the
oh I can see the light in the darkness
as the darkness bows to him I can hear
the RO
in the heavens as the space between
where I can feel the ground shake benath
us as the prison
WS nothing stands between
us nothing stands between us
[Music]
there is no other name but the name that
is
Jesus he who was and still is and will
be through it
all so come what may in the space
between all the things unseen and this
Reckoning I know I will never be alone
I know I will never be alone there'll be
another in the
fire standing next to me there'll be
water holding back the seats should I
ever
need how good you've been to me how
count the joy come
battle cuz I know that's where you'll
be I can see the light in the darkness
as the darkness bows to him I can hear
the roar in the heavens as a space
between I can feel the ground sh beneath
us as the prison W came in nothing
stands between us
nothing stands between there'll be
another in the
fire standing next to me there'll be
waters holding back the
SC I ever need
reming how good you been to me I'll
count the joy come every batt cuz I know
that's where you
be count the joy come
everybody cuz I know that's where you'll
be I'll count the joy come
[Music]
be man this this week I was practicing
that song and I text Joe I was like I
don't know that I'm going to make it
through that song on Sunday I literally
just busted out into tears and just wept
my way through it couldn't sing a single
word every time I opened my mouth it
just came out more like you know like
blubbering gushing it was hitting such a
sore spot in my heart of just those
times when you know things are not right
in the world um in your own world when
you just feel so alone and um even even
if you know in your head that's not true
you know the feeling can still be so
strong and um I just sang that song or
tried you know cried my way through that
song just
believing that though my feeling is that
I am alone though my feeling is that you
know name name the negative
emotion I can stand on the truth that he
is with us and I can stand on the
confidence that he will do a good work
and that's one of those phrases I know I
say up here all the time I know I pray
it all the time but it's because it's
one thing that I believe it's one thing
that I've hung on to through the highs
and the lows um through the questions
and the doubts and the
deconstruction it's that Jesus is who he
says he is that Jesus is a light and a
life and a source for us to hang on to
in the dark moments and this next song
we're going to do and I'm sorry I'm
talking so much um but I just really
quickly I wrote down a couple notes
because I myself had to go back and look
into scripture and see what are we
actually singing in this song it's
called we will feast in the house of
Zion um and it's by an artist that I
really love and I trust her music like
she's been proven to be one of those
artists that we as a band like go back
to we sing her songs um in this
community there's several of her things
that we do so I was like what what are
we saying here what are we singing when
we say the house of Zion cuz that's not
really like language that's you know
something we toss around like oh bless
House of Zion you know like we don't we
don't say that anymore and um Zion is
one of those words like Eden Eden was
like the beginning you know when things
were good and God established it and he
said it was good and Zion is like an
ending point where we return to that
goodness you know it's like two points
and in between is all the crazy and mess
but Zion is about coming back together
and being restored and there's two
verses that I just quickly wanted to
read in Isaiah that kind of talk about
Zion one is in chapter 35 and it says
and the ransomed of the Lord will return
they will enter Zion with singing
Everlasting Joy will Crown their heads
gladness and joy will overtake them and
sorrow and sighing will flee away
and then in chapter 51 it says the Lord
will surely Comfort Zion he will look
with compassion on all her ruins he will
make her deserts like Eden returning
being restored her wastelands like the
garden of the Lord joy and gladness will
be found in her again Thanksgiving and
the sound of
singing and it was just like holding on
to that hope that things may not always
be what they should be in the moment but
in in my heart I can hold on to this
truth that God is not finished he is
continuing to hold us he is our Center
he's what we return to and he promises
that we are moving towards Zion a place
where he gathers us back together a
place where we are restored where joy
and gladness will be on our
lips where our wastelands become Gardens
again
where what we had been sewing is going
to reap
fruit and you may not see it right now
in the moment we may look around our
world and see the devastation or the
sadness or the sorrow there is a lot of
unjust unright acts that are going in
our world and in our personal lives
there are things that are not right
right now but I just hold on to
Zion hold on to the promise of
restoration where he gathers us back
together and sets things right so as we
sing this May It Be Our Hope may we find
joy in the moment the Bible says uh
though though sadness May last for the
night Joy comes in the morning let's
hold on to that morning and believe it
that it will come
[Music]
we will feast in the house of
Zion we we will see with our hearts
restor he has done great things we will
stay
together we will feast and we no
more we will not be
bide the fire
is the Lord Our
God we are not
consumed by
[Music]
the
of
protected
GED
us we will Fe in the house of Zion
we will see with our hearts
Resto he has
done we will
stay
together we will feast and we no
more in the dark of
night before the
my
soul
[Music]
be for the promis
morning oh how
long oh god oh
J be
my he will feast in the house of Zion
we will sing in our hearts
rest he has done say things we will
say
together we will beast and we know
[Music]
oh every we
brok and betrayed
you are the
faithful
one and from the
light into the
grave
find
together bring
sh we will feast in the house of
we will see with our hearts
restor he has done great things we will
stay
together we
will and we no
more we will we
[Music]
scad will you remind us in the days
we're ready to throw in the towel in the
days that are dark and
troubling and we can't see a way
forward will you remind us that we are
not
alone that you don't give up on the work
of your hand that you have promised
us
[Music]
restoration you are the great
Redeemer you are the
light that draws us forward
that does a new
[Music]
thing the one who brings Gardens out of
graves God would you restore us would
you restore our
families our
homes our
communities we need
you we need the work of God
in our lives and in our
world thank you for staying with us
through it
all we love you Jesus and it's in your
name we pray all these things
[Music]
amen all right you guys can turn and say
hello to the people around you and then
Brett will start the
message well Grace and peace good to be
with you all so so good and uh I want to
give a warm welcome to those join us
online love youall Lots you're not
forgotten and uh yeah this just it's
good good to be together and uh here so
we are uh we're in the season of
epiphany in the church calendar right
now and this is The Season's all about
the revelation of Christ in the world
and really his ministry and kind of the
the invitation like what does that you
know mean for us as we kind of respond
and um you know along those lines it's
very kind of
Evangelistic uh kind of season and so
that'll be some of our topic and what
we're getting into tonight so the title
of the message is colonialism and
fishing for
people and our scripture is Luke 5: 1
through 11 very famous story it's like
the classic like Sunday school story if
you grew up in church we'd love that I
guess maybe anything with um creatures
you know fishes and nature and it's like
I guess we love that to teach the kids
you know yeah so um so this is Luke 5
one day as Jesus was standing by the
lake of janeret the people were crowding
around him him and listening to the word
of God he saw at the water's edge two
boats left there by the fishermen who
were washing their Nets he got into one
of the boats the one belonging to Simon
and asked him to put out a little from
the shore then he sat down and taught
the people from the boat when he had
finished speaking he said to Simon put
out into deep water and let down the
nets for a catch Simon answered Master
we've worked hard all night haven't
caught anything but because you say so I
will let down the Nets when they had
done so they caught such a large number
of fish that their Nets began to break
so they signaled uh their partners and
the other boat to come and help them and
then they came and filled both boats so
full that they began to sink when Simon
Peter saw this he fell at jesus' knees
and said go away from me Lord I'm a
sinful man for he and all his companions
were astonished at the catch of fish
they had taken and and so were James and
John the sons of zebede Simon's partners
then Jesus said to Simon Don't Be Afraid
from now on you will fish for
people so they pulled their boats up on
shore left everything and followed
him so I want to focus in on that that
last line of Jesus uh that I will from
now on I will make you fish for people
or you will fish for people and this is
a passage that's um all about that word
I used earlier evangelism which is you
can kind of hear it in this story right
where he's gonna send out uh Peter and
James and John to uh tell people about
Christ right and uh and that's kind of
the the work of of evangelism of
spreading the gospel and the good news
of Christ Life Death resurrection and uh
so of course we've you know you could
say maybe we live far enough
Downstream from
uh these words though that we've you
know we've have 2,000 years to kind of
see how this has played out uh both in
kind of beautiful life-giving ways and
in the not so much uh beautiful
life-giving ways uh so you know what's
that kind of looked like well on the um
kind of on the the upside or what this
is like at its best I I think of um
there's an example of a a film called
sacred Alaska uh which shares the story
of Orthodox uh Christian monks kind of
going across the way um and sharing with
the indigenous um cultures and people um
there in Alaska back in like it was like
the 1800s maybe early maybe late 17 or
early like
1800s and uh far from some sort of like
oh no you know went awful no no uh it
was it was beautiful it was stunning um
it was like missions work at its best
where it's not some which we'll get to
the worst stuff so so I won't I don't
need to go into that now but we just say
at its best it it ended up being this um
just a really kind of just like a
thoughtful sharing of Christ and really
a a sensitive kind of
synthesizing of the cultures of like
Christian theology belief that kind of
mapped on to their own indigenous kind
of
spirituality values theology culture and
so what they did was very carefully um
kind of bring these
together and it went so well that the
indigenous peoples there actually um not
only welcomed those monks but begged
them to send
more and so that film kind of tells the
the story of of how that um looked and
worked out and I think um I want to name
that because I think it's in our kind of
day and age where we are so attuned to
everything else that I'll get into in a
moment um I think it's easy to forget or
to maybe even think there's no way you
can do it you know you can't there's
just no way you start talking about
Jesus is just automatically sort of
awful or something you know and it's
like well not quite um and I want us to
kind of keep that keep that in mind
while
acknowledging uh the the other
side of things and uh that's yeah that's
kind of there as well
um I think it can be kind of summarized
in this phrase I'll call it religious
colonialism which is I'll kind of Define
it I'm drawing on the work of Ramon
panar he calls it a swallowing up right
so not a kind of thoughtful syntheis a
swallowing up of all other religions and
cultures and peoples with the pretention
of saving them and uh if you know kind
of some of your world history you know
this was a kind of religious mentality
that just W it fit hand in glove with
kind of the rise of Empires and nation
states who were very hungry not so much
for kind of religious transformation
right that was they left that to the
church in the religious folks they were
interested in kind of geographic
sociopolitical you know um kind of
conquest and then uh to kind of extract
resources labor you know from the
conquered peoples and uh that's you know
like tons of of world history and it was
uh oh it was quite awful I mean you can
see this you study American history uh
French history Dutch history I mean just
on and on it's like uh this is how um
much of the West has kind of run the
world you know sort of Empire after
Empire and uh and not just the West it's
even you go deeper into you know human
history and this is um often kind of the
story line and uh the way it was kind of
summarized quite brilliantly by Desmond
Tutu though I think he was actually kind
of drawing from um someone else but he's
the one who kind of popularized this
this statement where and he was by the
way a South African um Bishop uh and uh
and he's a a black man so he's you know
kind of coming from that angle so he put
it this way he said when the
missionaries came to Africa they had the
Bible and we had the land they said let
us pray we closed our eyes when we
opened them we had the Bible and they
had the land so that's right there
that's the story of kind of colonialism
melding in with religious colonialism
and you know uh all of it's kind of
jacked up history so um now I think the
thing is we've got to keep in mind these
so there you have kind of a contrast
right you have kind of sacred Alaska and
and how it's been thoughtfully shared
there and not just there I mean you can
find other examples um and then you have
this other kind of way this swallowing
up of cultures kind of path and um what
I want to kind of shift into talking
about isn't so much sort of world
history and how this plays out if you
know if you're a missionary this is how
you should do it or something um I want
to talk more about here and now because
this is I think we have to bring the
same kind of um care and thoughtfulness
and sensitivity to our own kind of
interpersonal conversations with people
um even here and now um in our own day
our own time and uh Charles Kaiser who
uh many of you know now since he and his
family are part of the table he wrote a
wonderful book I've talked about before
and I will continue it's just it's so
good it's called trauma-informed
evangelism and a great read and in it he
talks about how um basically in America
you need to bring the same level of
sensitivity and thoughtfulness um
because of the history right because of
um how this is played out in America I
mean you think of it like um like it's
very rare that I speak with someone and
that either a start talking about you
know Jesus Christianity Church whatever
the a they're like huh oh that's
interesting I'm not familiar um tell me
yeah tell me more or what Jesus you
that's a very rare person I honestly at
this point I don't think I've met
anyone ever you know so like it's pretty
well known at this point right um or B
oh yeah somebody says oh Christianity
Jesus Culture Church yeah or yeah yeah
I've heard U and I used to be super
involved um actually I don't even know
why I'm not anymore kind of faded away
but honestly I have nothing but
wonderful memories of it and I can you
invite me please you know invite me back
to church um again that's a I think
these folks they do exist um as we know
they are increasingly vanishingly
rare and so that's that's why you can't
just kind of barge in like I got Jesus
you know um I've and I've talked with
with people um well I've been that
person who's kind of been more you know
I'm going to save people and man you
start like it I think it often comes
from a good heart of a real experience
of the love of Christ and like wanting
to share that with people but it starts
getting wonky when you're just not
taking into
consideration the actual history of the
thing right in other words you could
read Luke 5 verse1 be like well Jesus
told me and kind of launch out an
Evangelistic Zeal without a certain like
well yes but you know history has
happened you're not coming to people who
haven't Jesus who what huh Church
Christianity huh huh like that's just
generally 99% of the time that's not
right and so that shifts and changes
things so um back in high school I went
on a mission trip to New York City where
um door to door evangelism figured very
prominently in that trip and I don't
know anyone done any door too oh brave
souls and so we we it was it was strange
like our our kind of opening or our
angle our way to get to talking to
people was we had this survey now did
the church who was kind of sponsoring us
and like giving us a survey and did they
tell us that this is a fake
survey no um did they seem super
interested in the data that we brought
back each
evening no you know sort of like these
papers oh thank you you know because of
course the survey was just an inn right
it was just a to get the conversation
going so that's very hard to just walk
to someone like hey want to hear about
Jesus you know um so to get the
conversation going and B it was of
course a religious survey so the
questions right you could kind of
quickly discern is this person already a
Christian or a churchgoer you know where
they coming from and then you kind of
figure out you know how to share it I'll
never forget though I'm going around the
whole time I felt very uneasy about this
this the whole thing you know was just
kind of like but you know I want to be a
Christian I wanted to be a I don't know
obedian or something so um I'll never
forget that one woman like very quickly
I don't know maybe she was a former
Christian or something but I launched
into the survey and like within like two
questions she's like wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait she's like
This is BS you're just here to talk to
me about Jesus you're just trying to
convert you know like she just totally
calls me and I just froze because I was
like yeah that's true you know um and
yeah it was weird because like here we
were trying to share about the beauty
the Integrity the truth of Christ and
yet we were using these strategies and
kind of manipulative means like lies to
go about it it just the whole thing it
just felt off and weird it was gross uh
Charles in his book wrote it this way he
said much imagination about evangelism
is disordered and produces spiritual
abuse and Trauma for this reason
evangelism is a dirty word to many It's
associated with superiority coercion
imperialism domination exploitation and
colonization
many Christians have abandoned the
practice of evangelism because of these
associations that's is that something
you can relate to just feeling kind of
like very hesitant you know like uh I
just don't want to go here he says if
that's the extent of evangelism an Abus
of power play towards Outsiders well
then it should absolutely be discarded
but if evangelism could be something
different something healing something
that's actually good news to the
church's neighbors then it should be
deconstructed in and
reformed later on that same page he said
what if evangelism is simply loving our
neighbors
well I think that's a great reframing
and that's really what I want to do
tonight and what I want us to think of
Evangel I want us instead of discarding
it I want us to start to reframe it like
what if it's just loving people well and
that that in and of itself becomes uh
some something like becomes good news
for
people like in other words when Jesus
says I will make you Fishers of people
rather than that having to be this kind
of well I've got to you know force it
upon people or run from it and abandon
it what if it could be kind of reod
because I think the truth is um as I you
know am in the culture along with you
all as as uh kind of hurt
by church and uh all of it you know as
as people have been um often as they try
to exit what they find
there is
uh a kind of secular a sort of a a vague
nothingness like it's kind of a thin
belief system and structure you know
sort of maybe they retain a certain
vague belief in God
um uh maybe kind of hold on to a few
things from Christianity or something
about love is good or something you know
but in essence they've kind of lost the
broader story that situates and makes
sense of some of those uh those beliefs
and so and I've also found people um I
think are still very like hungry
for love are still very um in need of
like being listened to and
heard and
respected which is where I think this
kind of uh forceful kind of Evangelistic
Zeal can be really hurtful um so I think
in essence in a pluralistic kind of post
Christendom World evangelism must be
rooted in loving dialogue not coercive
monologue so here's um I want to unpack
this in kind of four ways so what what
does this mean evangelism as dialogue
what does this look like number one I
think it's it's
slow you might say that evangelism as
dialogue just kind of moves at the pace
of love and
relationship instead of well often like
those tragedies you heard you know my
story a moment ago about kind of going
to order door that's a very fast form of
evangelism you know what I mean like and
I think it's often driven by anxiety
these people are going to hell so we got
to get them out of hell and so you just
kind of you know kind of emote your own
anxiety all over them and
uh yeah we need we need something slower
something like okay chill out chill out
um how can you be a healing life-giving
loving presence to this
person and uh that changes things right
Suddenly It's about um I Say More Than
Words at first really it's just about
like relationship about
caring not coming with some
agenda so that's the first thing um the
goal is simply to love second
evangelism as dialogue It's
Curious is this something that other
forms of evangelism I think almost
always lack you know because it's it's
really um someone who's much more
interested as we'll get to next about
talking you know what I mean so you
often lack any curiosity like
so who are
you you know like what do you
think where are you coming from you know
and and being genu like genuinely like
I'm interested I mean those of you who
know me like I am I am curious as a cat
about like what people believe and why
and the the stories the history you know
like what's kind of LED them um to this
point and uh I I will name this is where
kind of doing a little reading at least
to kind of be familiar with your own
tradition and the ideas beliefs
traditions of others can go a long way
because then you have some feel for what
to ask you know you kind of know even
some of the common ground and can start
to dialogue and um have a good
conversation you know because you you um
yeah you can ask better better questions
um third evangelism as dialogue is
listening right so in other words this
isn't about okay we'll start with
curiosity listen for 3
minutes and then 55 minutes of your you
know your monologue and what they need
to change and like no no no um true
genuine conversation it has to be this
you know this beautiful give and take
there's a certain spontaneity to it um
you have to make room for people to
share and that that really um it's about
honoring people you know honoring not
even just their like intellectual
beliefs but I mean even their stories
just who they are give them space give
them them room and it also allows you to
begin to discern like like this is one
of my kind of um pre what's the term
um
uh kind of a thing sorry what prere was
it kind of no like a pre uh well it
doesn't matter here's one of my guiding
assumptions that's okay kind of you know
what pre yeah okay that's a good one
presupposition is like the Holy Spirit
spirit is active and present to people
myself included always and at all
times and is calling
drawing all of us towards the God who is
love so it's not so much my job to like
to you know like get them on the right
path it's it's more like I'm trying to
discern what's God calling me to in this
what's God calling them to in this right
it's a very um kind of yeah dialogue and
and a way of of working that's it's
listening it's speaking it's right this
back and forth so I name listening
because I think we usually come to the
speaking part easily enough you know we
usually don't have that trouble in a
conversation um so we got to emphasize
the the listening aspect of it um okay
fourth and finally evangelism as
dialogue is
non-controlling non-controlling you can
go ahead and repeat these words after me
I excellent y'all are good am not not
the holy the holy spirit Spirit yes this
is very important to remember because
this is where I think Christians get
super weird is instead of sort of
trusting God's got him Christ has got
him and I'm here to love to be present
and and just like I want them to do to
me you know what I mean like I I hope
they're not kind of super anxious for me
what I believe and and you trust me I
know what it's like to go through life
where people are often very worried
about me and that's not helpful you know
I mean I'd rather talk with someone who
sort of is in that non-anxious posture
of look I'm not the Holy Spirit and I
trust God's leading you so let's work
through this together um and I think
nowhere is that more important than when
it comes to engaging these kinds of
conversations across perhaps cultural um
religious you know boundaries and lines
woo we we got to um let go of the the
the weird control uh kind of mode and I
will say I think this is why evangelism
happens um best by accident and what I
mean is that it's just I think at its
best it's so relational and kind of
laidback that the spirit is doing things
that we don't even realize uh she's up
to and yet right like I said God's
always there and present and and
moving and uh I I I'll close the story a
few many years ago back I had a a good
friend we're still in touch but but um
he was just going through a really just
an incredibly difficult season in his
life when I met him and uh through some
conversations I I mean I could tell just
from his uh history and things like oh
he could use a friend you know right now
so we just started getting you know
coffee and things and uh he knew this
was before I was pastoring so um but he
knew I was a Christian and through
conversations I kind of picked up like
he didn't grow up going to church or
anything like that and uh and that was
fine like occasionally we'd get on to
religious topics or something but like
not not really not super often or
anything so we met for coffee just
getting know each other you know just
friends and supporting one another and
all that so like fast forward like five
years and one day we're grabbing coffee
and he's like well I got a
Bible and my jaw almost hit the floor I
was like you got a Bible he's like yep I
just uh I feel
like it's time it's time for me and God
to
like start getting right I mean you
could tell like he's not isn't there's
not a lot of I get I see the eyes y'all
are like what huh well because y'all are
um you know well kind of you're like
longtime Christians you know what I mean
he's not at all like no very none you
know so for him was a very simp kind of
simple-hearted like I just realized like
I need God in my life life so yeah I
think I'm going going to go to church I
was
like great man that's great and from
there was kind of I was so honestly I
was stunned the whole time because I'm
like wa what I realized is through just
relationship um in essence I'd been
evangelizing him quote unquote you know
what I mean but without the weirdness
without the control and this and that
okay you better get right with God and
you know it's like all that went away
and without even trying just by being
present to him uh God did this like
beautiful work in his life and it's been
remarkable to see it like in the 10
years since then no matter what town he
moves to he's like continued to engage
and um loves to he tell me about like
the recent he loves music so he'll tell
me about the recent worship songs he's
playing like that's wonderful it is it's
kind of been this beautiful um unfolding
in his own heart and mind of um what it
looks like for him you know to to love
God and uh I wonder if that's like a
little bit of what at its best kind of
at least in this day and age you know in
in a time where so many people have been
hurt by the church and where so many
Christianity is often dominated by this
kind of image of the the hard charging
you know
believer um I wonder if a a more kind of
relational loving posture um is is
what's needed um as opposed to a
pendulum swing towards
just totally hands off um and kind of
letting Jesus words here about I will
make you Fishers of people like letting
that go I I don't want to let that go I
think um people are in need of the love
of God and uh and I want the us as a
community to be a people who are
bridging to folks meeting them where
they're at and attuned um to what the
Holy Spirit might be up to so um yeah so
that's my heart in the name of the
father the Son and the Holy Spirit
amen
so on the night that Jesus was
betrayed he had one final meal with his
disciples and at that meal he held up a
loaf of bread and he broke it and he
said take it and eat this is my body
that's broken for you and he held up cup
of wine he said this is my blood shed
for you take it and
drink and so for 2,000 years Christians
have gathered at the table to reenter on
Christ to remember his love and then to
be sent out as Fishers of people uh to
Bridge and connect with others so as you
come forward tonight um may it be a
moment where God meets you reenters you
regr grounds you in that that great love
so uh the way we'll go about this
tonight we'll just go row by row forming
a line here um we practice an open table
so everyone's welcome here at the table
of Christ remember the red is wine the
white is grape juice and then finally
you can just partake whenever and
however you'd like so this is the table
not of the church but of the Lord and
it's made ready for those who love him
and for those who want to love him more
so come you who have much faith and you
who have little you who have been here
often and you who have not been here
long you who have tried to follow and
you who failed
come come because it's the Lord Jesus
himself who invites you and it's his
will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here come to the table
[Music]
if you guys want to stand with us we're
going to close again and let's just sing
about this hope that we have to share
and offer through our presence through
our love of our neighbor as we um as we
go out into our world let's hang on to
this hope
[Music]
we will feast in the house of
Zion we will sing with our hearts
restored we have done great things we
will
say
together we will
feast and we no more
oh
oh no
no
[Music]
more every bow we
broken in the
train you
are a
faithful
one and from the
guide into the
grave bind
us together
[Applause]
[Music]
we will feast in the house of
Zion we will sing with our hearts
Resto he has done bra things we will
St
together we will
feast and weap no more
we leave
[Music]
no thank you all so much for being here
with us tonight um if you're new we
would love for you to fill out the QR
code that's about to be on the screen
just to say thanks for being here and to
answer any questions you might have
about uh what this community looks like
we could all use more relational support
and spiritual connection and the way we
do that here is through meetups um if
you're not yet part of a Meetup you can
also scan that QR code um to find one
that works for
you generosity is a key aspect of a life
of adoration and worship if the table is
your church home and we invite you to
scan the QR code to get financially or
to visit the TBL tx.org
okay now I'm going to send you into your
week with a blessing you can hold out
your hands in a posture to receive or
just open your heart to these
words you are a child of
God you are a child of
God this is true on your best day
and it's true on your worst day so as
you go into your week ahead with it's
yet to be determined highs and lows and
everything in between go filled with the
assurance that you are loved you are
worthy and you are accepted just as you
are and go filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire to extend these same
Gifts of Grace and unconditional love to
everyone you come into contact with
be blessed and we'll see you next Sunday
thank
[Music]
you we will feast in the house of
Zion we will sing with our hearts
Resto he has